the two decisions to lift currency
restrictions and scrap export taxes will
expose Latin America's third largest
economy to international market forces
in ways not seen for a dozen years
former President Cristina Fernandez
kirschner restricted foreign currency
purchases in 2011 to shore up dwindling
foreign currency reserves most
Argentines who wanted to buy dollars
were limited to a few hundred dollars a
month when US currency was available in
banks at all now that's been changed
those who want to export will be able to
export without asking for permission
those who want to import can import
without permission those who want to buy
dollars can buy dollars those who want
to sell dollars no one is going to go
after them this is how a normal economy
functions in any part of the world over
the last year while the official
exchange rate was fixed around nine
argentine pesos to the dollar a dollar
fetched as much as 16 pesos on the black
market businesses especially those
needing to deal in dollars were deeply
affected while the change will be
celebrated by international investors
and welcomed by many Argentines many
fear a sharp devaluation of the peso and
what that might do to already soaring
prices